- Hey, do you wanna go down to the beach
and we'll both roller skate
with a rope in between us
until we get so much centrifugal force
that we fly into billboards?
- Yeah, but can I do,
like, a sweet grind, first?
- Of course you can!
But if any humans come, run.
Gushers commercials,
where all the kids' heads
turned into fruit.
- Turned into fruit
and they exploded.
No one was concerned!
- Nobody died.
- No one was concerned.
- [Voiceover] Making funny faces was
such a big deal back then.
(sucking noises)
Hate the man?
Make funny faces.
The man hates funny faces.
- This Pop Tart spinning through
the vacuum of space is incredible.
- What is this part where a plane
flies around an apple?
- It's part of a well-balanced breakfast.
- What are you talking about?
I never eat airplanes for breakfast.
- This is the girl from The O.C. as a kid.
- That's not Misha Barton, no way.
- That's totally Misha Barton!
(laughing)
- Plain daylight, no one's at the beach?
Hard to believe, Capri Sun.
- See, it's like Alex Mack!
- Boom, straight into the billboard.
Walking through a fence
- That was pretty cool.
- Was like the coolest
thing you could ever do.
- Oh my God!
- No (silly noises)
- He is a demon!
- Parents were so nervous that kids
were just having sex and doing drugs,
but these kids were just like,
I'm hungry for cereal!
- Kids dressed so cool back then.
They always had, like, a bike helmet on
for no reason.
- This kid is dressed like
the Fresh Prince of Bel Air.
- I still think he's cute.
I kind of love him.
- He's not not cute, but
he's also terrifying.
- I love how they always
add, like, the toast
with the one thing of butter.
And milk and orange juice.
Come on, Mom!
- Raccoon looking for food in the winter.
- Wait, is that?
- No, no!
- It's gonna be a snowboard, you idiot!
(laughing)
- Oh my God.
- Oh my God!
- Bam. Animal cruelty.
- What's that movie, with
Arnold Schwarzenegger,
when his eyes burst out of his head?
- Twins.
- No.
- [Man] Stupid idea.
[Woman] His outfit is amazing!
- Aw, man, that's what
rad dudes looked like.
- I wanna be a rad dude.
- When I think about why
I loved the '90s so much,
I just think about watching TV.
- I think these commercials
promoted the fact
that it's super cool to be a kid.
- I definitely got enough
of a nostalgia dose
just watching these.
- Kids like goofy bull
(beep) and I know it.
And it's cool.
Goofy bull (beep) is great.
(funky music)
- I'm big in goofy bull (shit),
but I just don't buy it as much anymore.
I make it now.